today on the matt walsh show a new
survey reveals that huge numbers of
americans have left religion in recent
years especially since covid but that's
not actually correct americans aren't
leaving religion they're going from one
religion to a different one i'll explain
also ron desantis continues to lead the
charge against wokeness in the school
system and airline ceos try to explain
why it's stupid to require masks on
planes plus a leading climate activist
and quote-unquote scientist calls for
more censorship of climate denialism
enter a daily cancellation camilla
harris is cancelled but perhaps not for
the reasons you may think all of that
and more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's the holidays and you deserve a gift
how about a gift that keeps on giving
you joy and comfort every day all year
long this is a gift for yourself not for
anybody else don't waste it on somebody
else i'm talking about the x chair you
want to get the x chair for yourself um
i absolutely love mine it's by far the
most comfortable and uh ergonomic chair
i've ever used i don't even know what
ergonomic means i just know that it is
that and honestly it's also probably the
coolest looking piece of furniture i own
not only is x-chair the world's greatest
office chair but with its patented lmx
technology it doubles as a massage chair
and can either cool or warm your back as
well
can your office chair do that probably
not
which is why you need the x chair now is
the perfect time to purchase the next
chair buy early
buy now and um and here's extra's
holiday gift for you you can save 100
off your ex chair just by purchasing it
at xchairwalsh.com
that's the letter x chair walsh.com
xchair has a 30 day guarantee of
complete comfort and you can finance
your purchase for as little as 30 bucks
a month go to xchairwalsh.com and save
that's exchairwalsh.com the media has
been reporting this week with a certain
amount of unsubtle glee that a huge
chunk of americans abandoned their
religion over the last two years
accelerating an already existing trend
this trend is certainly important it's
one of the most important and
consequential things happening in our
world today in fact our society is being
fundamentally reshaped as we speak
but as always the media reports
tend to miss the point while also
misinterpreting the data
there is a great religious shift taking
place
but i don't think it's accurate to say
that all of these people are leaving
religion necessarily and i'll explain
why but first let's take a look at the
findings
as reported by the wall street journal
it says quote
religious affiliation in the u.s has
continued to fall during the pandemic
according to a new survey from the pew
research center the percentage of
americans who identify as christians now
stands at 63 percent down from 65 to
2019 and from 78 78 in 2007. meanwhile
29 of americans now identify as having
no religion up from 26 in 2019 and 16
in 2007 when pew began tracking
religious identity many places of
worship closed during the pandemic some
voluntarily others as a result of state
and local social distancing rules and
in-person church attendance is roughly
30 to 50 percent lower than it was
before the pandemic
estimates estimates barn barna group a
research firm that studies faith in the
us uh uh in the u.s millions of
americans move to worshiping online and
questions linger about how many will
come back to the in-person worshiping
so let's pause for a moment to consider
two points
first of all these numbers are indeed
truly horrifying if you are a member of
a traditional religion
and if you agree with john adams who
said that our political system was made
only for a moral and religious people
and is wholly inadequate to the
government of any other
if you do then this should trouble you
greatly
dropping from 78 christian to 63
in less than 15 years is cataclysmic
even more so when you take a step back
and consider the fuller picture polls of
this kind conducted back say in the
1950s would have found that well over 90
percent of the country was christian
all that's almost everybody
now we're and certainly you know 90
christian
and then the rest would be other
religions
there'd be almost nobody who identified
as non-religious
now we're on track as christians to be a
minority
and that will happen far sooner than you
think i would give it maybe until the
middle of this decade another five years
perhaps
of course we're already a minority and
have been for some time if you take into
account that not every self-identified
christian is really a christian
that's the problem with a survey like
this you know you're not going to find
anyone who self-identifies as
non-christian and yet actually is
christian that doesn't happen the
christian religion is such that if you
think you aren't in it
then you aren't
but just because you think you are in it
doesn't mean you are
case in point joe biden if he was
contacted for this survey uh he would
have said yeah i'm christian but he
rejects nearly every moral teaching of
the catholic church and denies its moral
authority and yet would call himself
catholic and thus christian he's not
his claim is at best self-delusion but
probably more likely a conscious lie
all of that to say
um
you know let's not engage in
self-delusion ourselves and pretend that
these kinds of survey findings aren't
important or that the situation isn't
really as bad as this makes it seem
it is that bad and in fact it's worse
we were once a christian nation
we are no longer a christian nation
soon we won't even be a majority
christian nation
and as our founders knew
this doesn't work
it's not working
the country doesn't work when it when it
is not anchored in the christian faith
another point church attendance is
perhaps as it says 50 lower than it was
two years ago
so churches lost half
half of their congregations in the span
of two years
and they're not coming back okay
and this squares with my own anecdotal
experience for what it's worth every
church i've attended over the last year
has been relatively sparse in attendance
i'm not sure i've seen a full church
except on holidays since 2019.
and even back then it was somewhat rare
to see a totally full church now you
just never see them
why i mean why have people abandoned
going to church part of it of course is
the decline in traditional religious
religiosity the decline in christian
affiliation generally but the drop-off
for church attendance is far outpacing
the drop in christian affiliation
why is that a big part of the reason for
that is that many churches most i'm
guessing
closed their doors often for months at a
time during the pandemic during a time
when people most needed spiritual
guidance
and spiritual formation
and leadership
the church wasn't there
it had it had fled
in the night in fear
now you might rationalize that churches
were forced to do this the government
told them they had to close down the
problem is that many remained closed
even when they no longer had to be
closed and even during the time when
they had to be closed they can still be
faulted for complying with the with
these absurdly unconstitutional edicts
closing down
the right to to the free
exercise of religion is right there in
the first amendment
governments coming in and shutting down
churches indefinitely
certainly flies in the face of that so
the government had no moral authority to
shut down any churches
which means the church has had the moral
authority to refuse and say we're not
shutting down you can arrest us all
we're not shutting down
a few churches did that
heroically
most did not
most just shut their doors and said okay
you let us know when we can go back to
practicing our religion again
so through this mixture of compliance
and willful cooperation churches sent a
message to the public and the message
was you don't need us
we aren't necessary
you can get along fine without us
and great numbers of people heard that
message and they took it to heart and
now here we are
but there's another very important point
to make about all this but first let's
go back to the article for a minute
it says among the 29 percent who say
they have no religion four percent say
they are theists and five percent
agnostic
most of those figures are unchanged
since 2017.
the percentage of americans who identify
as nothing in particular grew from 16 in
2017 to 20 this year
though some who identify as nothing in
particular may believe in god uh mr
smith said they are far less likely to
pray or attend services than americans
who identify with a religious group the
share of americans who prayed daily fell
to 45 of 2021 compared with 58
in 2007.
it says the secularizing trends that
have been evident for a long time show
no signs of slowing and certainly no
signs of reversing
though protestants remain the largest
group most of the drop in religious
affiliation has come from their ranks
some 40 percent of americans now
identify as protestant compared with 43
in 2019 and 52 in 2007.
okay now to the important point
what we're witnessing is not really a
decline in religion per se at least not
uh at least the decline is not is not
nearly as steep as those numbers make it
seem
because many of the non-religious people
have not given up on religion or left
religion
they have just in fact changed religions
this is a religious shift
not a drop
and to understand this we have to take a
step back i think and consider what we
even mean when we say the word religion
what is a religion
most dictionary definitions will tell
you that a religion is you know a belief
and some kind of supernatural entity
with associated rituals and customs
attached to that belief and that is one
form that religion takes yes
most of the ancient religions
the traditional religions
take exactly that form
but i think i prefer a broader
definition that helps to make sense of
what we're seeing in our culture today
i would say that religion can be defined
as simply a shared sense
of transcendent meaning
and it has to be shared because religion
by definition cannot be a totally
individualized pursuit if it is then
it's just a belief not a religion and
then there has to be that sense of
transcendence or else it's not a
religion it's a social club
to be in a religion is to look towards
something transcendent something beyond
ordinary physical experience
and to be standing alongside others who
are looking in the same direction as you
now this means again that some of those
self-described christians aren't really
christian at all aren't really religious
at all
because when you go to some churches
today there is no sense of anything
transcendent at all
everything is earthbound
all of the focus is on earthly
priorities and values
i mean you can go to some so-called
churches today and not even see a cross
anywhere in the building
because the cross
is transcendence
and in these churches they don't want
you looking to anything transcendent
and the people in those churches they're
not attending a church they're attending
a motivational seminar
or maybe a book club
in fact many christian churches have
taken great pains over the decades to
deliberately turn away from the
transcendent and the mystical and to
make the church-going experience far
more sterile and sanitized in that way
which is another reason why fewer people
are going to church because you've
removed the very thing that motivated
them to come in the first place
but what about all those self-described
non-religious people
those allegedly non-religious people
well a good portion of them are leftists
not all but a good portion
and leftism is a religion in itself
it may not have all of the same
structured customs and traditions part
of what defines it is its hostility to
customs and traditions
its tradition is to destroy tradition
religious people of the past you know
built statues and monuments members of
the leftist religion tear down statues
and monuments
but even so it is a religion
and this becomes quite obvious when you
consider critical race theory the belief
in inherited racial guilt
inherited racial persecution
gender theory the belief that people can
be born in the wrong bodies
the belief that a man can be a man and
yet somehow still in some way be a woman
at the same time
all of the pronouns and the new gender
labels and so on none of this is
scientific
it certainly isn't
logical
there's no empirical basis to any of
this
they cannot locate the source of white
guilt or black victimization
or
a man's womanhood
anywhere on earth
this is their version of grasping for
transcendent meaning
there's a reason why they hold that
prefix trans in such high regard
they put it all the way at the top of
the pyramid
because that's really what they mean
when they call a man a trans woman they
mean that he is a transcendent woman
his womanhood transcends physical
boundaries making him in many ways a
more spectacular specimen of womanhood
than a biological woman
that's how a man won woman of the year a
few years ago
their ideas about race gender victimhood
justice fairness equity tolerance all of
these ideas have a religious
supernatural transcendent quality to
them and to call it transcendent by the
way is not an endorsement
transcendent just means that something
is beyond the range of normal human
experience psychosis is a transcendent
experience too in a certain way
there is transcendence that points you
to truth and beauty
which is christian transcendence
and then there is the religion of
leftism which is a religion
but one that directs you towards
confusion
and insanity
um
you know the idea of christian
transcendence is you're looking beyond
the physical you're looking beyond your
immediate experiences
and then anchoring yourself to something
beyond it but something that's even more
real
something sturdier
with the leftist transcendence you're
looking beyond physical experience
and uh
just going out there into space and
floating around not anchored to anything
untethered unmoored
that's what we're witnessing in our
culture today
it's not the death of religion but the
birth of a new one an anti-religion
religion but a religion all the same
one with its own supernatural beliefs
its own heresies
its own anti-tradition traditions
its own ideas about sin its own
inquisitions
human beings as we discover are
religious by nature
you're never going to have a totally
non-religious society it can't happen
there will always be religion the only
question is if we choose a true religion
or a false one
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well i never had a garage until recently
with our most recent house and uh i've
one once you have one then you discover
that it's it is a frequently traversed
area in your house in fact garages are
the most frequently accessed entry point
for for most homes often overlooked the
garage is where the uh the most where
people you know come and go and you also
keep a lot of really important things
there prized possessions including your
cars your tools and bikes so it's just
common sense to know what's going on
inside your garage introducing the myq
smart camera by chamberlain the only
smart camera optimized for the garage
brought to you by the leaders in garage
door opener technology you can pair it
with the myq smart garage control
and that's a great thing if you're uh
you know ocd like i am and you check
everything make sure the garage door is
shut and then you're leaving for work
and five minutes later you're thinking
did i shut the garage well just pull out
your phone on your app and you can shut
the garage you can check on everything
with that app the myq camera is easy to
install you can quickly connect it to
your phone via bluetooth in the my queue
app it's as simple as that so what are
you waiting for give the give the gift
of a myq smart garage camera to tech
lovers this season if you act now you
can save 46 for a limited time by
entering walsh at checkout on myq dot
com slash walsh that's wall should check
out myq dot com slash walsh to say 46
keep an eye on what's happening in and
around your home's busiest entryway with
the myq smart garage camera it's the
only smart camera optimized for the
garage all right let's uh start with
this ron desantis
yesterday introduced um a bill called
the sto the stop woke act
and he's someone fighting back against
the leftist religion especially as it
intrudes into the school system
you know separation of church and state
the people who are who are bringing this
wokeness
into the school system they're the ones
who would say we have to separate church
and state
but what they really mean again is that
they don't mean that what they mean is
no we we want our own church
we don't want we don't want religion out
of the school system what are you
talking about no we want our religion in
the school system not yours
uh desantis is fighting back against
that let's listen to him explain the
bill
so today we are going to be introducing
to the public and and we have
legislators who are going to help us
with this
a new piece of legislation for the
upcoming legislative session called stop
wrongs against our kids and employees
act the stop woke act and it's something
that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and this will do a number of things that
are very important one it will put into
statute uh the department of education's
prohibition
on crt in k-12 schools no
taxpayer dollars should be used to teach
our kids to hate our country or to hate
each other
so we're seeing from ron desantis and i
and
i i think
finally more conservatives are waking up
to this fact
um
that we can't sit back in a totally
defensive posture
uh there needs to be an aggressive
offensive move
to keep this stuff out of school systems
uh to protect our kids from it
and i don't think anyone's doing more
than that
from a political standpoint than ron
desantis uh but he's he
he he made another really interesting
point about this i want to there's one
more clip i want to play from this press
conference as he's talking about you
know
with leftism what are their real
priorities
what do they care about the most they
talk about taxes and and tax policy but
is that what they actually care about
the most uh here he is talking about
that
and i think what you see now with the
rise of this woke ideology uh is an
attempt to really delegitimize our
history and to delegitimize our
institutions and i view the wokeness as
a form of cultural marxism uh they want
to tear
[Applause]
they want to just it's not just you know
people say oh you know you know they're
they're uh they're they're leftists or
socialists not just like taxes and all
that yeah they do want that and that's
not good but they really want to tear at
the fabric of our society and our
culture and and things that really we've
taken for granted like the ability of
parents to direct the upbringing of
their kids
yeah uh
and and the only the only thing i
quibble with here is he says uh they're
trying to delegitimize
our institutions they're trying to
delegitimize our history
and he's right about that
but that's also
really we should be talking in the past
tense because they've already done it
you know they've already succeeded
they have taken over the institutions
they have delegitimized our history
they've gone through at will and torn
down the statues and monuments
and more importantly they've they have
managed
to reshape the way that especially our
kids view their own history
and now many kids today
see american history not as something to
be proud of but as something that's a
source of great shame and guilt
something that we cannot it's offensive
to celebrate it
so the point is this has already
happened
and uh it's it's important for us to
realize that and acknowledge it not so
that we can
fall into despair and say oh what was me
were beat
but we have to understand that this is
not that's why i say we're going on the
offensive
it's it's too late for to take a
defensive posture
it's too late to say oh we have to uh
we have to defend we have to defend our
our institutions
it's too late for that
they they ha they have the institutions
we can't defend them
now it's a matter of taking them back
so even if we wanted to i think
conservatives for decades took a
defensive posture
while the left was on the offense
and we saw what happened they won
and now it's too late to be defensive
the fort has been taken
now we're on the outside and we have to
take it back and so i see this not as a
defensive move but an offensive move
that's exactly what we need okay next
from the daily wire it says the ceos of
two of america's largest airlines said
this week that they do not believe
that the buy administration's continued
mask mandate requiring travelers to wear
masks while flying serves much benefit
considering the fact that airplanes have
advanced filtration systems that remove
nearly all airborne contamination from
the cabin
the comments from american airlines ceo
doug parker and southwest airlines ceo
greg gary kelly came on
wednesday during a senate committee
hearing on the financial support the
industry received during the pandemic
cnn reported both kelly and parker who
each have announced plans to retire as
ceos in the coming months mention that
high-grade hepa air filters on planes
capture virtually all airborne
contamination and air quality is helped
by how frequently cabin air is exchanged
with fresh air from outside the cabin
kelly said quote i think the case is
very strong that masks don't add much if
anything in the air cabin environment
is very safe and very high quality
compared to any other indoor setting
uh parker agreed saying i concur an air
an aircraft is the safest place you can
be
parker added it's true all of our
aircraft they all have the same hepa
filters and air flow
so
what does that mean it means that the
despite common misperceptions about
airplanes because you kind of think of
it as you're stuck in this metal tube
with a hundred other people in close
proximity you're all packed in there
like sardines breathing each other's air
that's not the case at all because
you're 35 000 feet in the air
and they're filtering and cleaning that
air aggressively
much more than any other indoor
environment
and then you've got the air from the
outside that's filtered in which is 35
000 feet in the air so it's very clean
so you've got this really clean air on
airplanes actually
by putting the masks on
now you're you're breathing your own air
back in
so you you could argue
that um you're getting dirtier air than
you would otherwise if you just didn't
have the mask on you could argue that
it would seem that these airline ceos
are arguing that
uh
there's
it would seem they're arguing what they
are saying just to be clear to youtube
what what these airline ceos are saying
is that
the masks are basically pointless on the
airplane
but
um
we are being conditioned
to do things that don't make sense
as we know as we've talked about for
months this is about power
we are conditioned to do things that
don't make sense for reasons that nobody
can explain
simply because we're told to do them
and nowhere is that more obvious and
pronounced than on an airplane
where you're sitting there and this has
also by the way completely changed the
employee customer relationship in a lot
of different ways and none of them good
ways
because now flight attendants in the
past the flight attendant is uh is is
there to you're the customer you're
paying a lot of money to be on that
plane
and um and in the past the flight
attendant is there is is there to serve
you
and to help you
that's a flight attendant they are there
to attend to you
that's why they're there
in the past
and now they've become these kind of
hectoring brow beating authority figures
if you've been on a plane at any point
in the last two years you know this this
is the main thing that flight attendants
do now this is their primary occupation
is mask enforcement and so they're
walking through
and some flight attendants are more
relaxed about it than others
in my experience most are not relaxed
and they're just walking through and
they're enforced and they're yelling at
you about masks that's that's primarily
what they're doing
and they're even keeping track you know
they're like they have a stop watch out
basically
[Music]
because you could turn you could pull
the mask down to eat but they want to
make sure that it's not down for i saw
someone get yelled at for that in my
last flight
a guy pulled his mask down
was eating
but you're supposed to pull the mask
back up in between bites
and he actually got yelled at about that
i've been yelled at because uh you know
originally i had made the mistake
the awful transgression of um
when it was time to eat
you know i would just take i took the
mask off completely so that i could
enjoy my meal without this chin with
without a pointless chin strap on and i
was told no you can't take it off
completely you have to just pull it down
it has to be right over the chin
that to keep
other people safe from your chin fumes
or something i don't know
um and that's what that's what flight
attendants do now they they have become
these authority figures
and so the whole experience now of
flying
is just
you go through tsa
you're treated like a suspected criminal
like a terrorist just because you want
to get on a flight
they could pat you down send you through
all this kind of they're yelling at you
and then you get on the plane and you're
treated like a biological hazard
and this whole time you are paying
exorbitant amounts of money for this
experience
to get treated like
dirt and filth
and all of this is in service
at least when it comes to the masks it's
in service of something that doesn't
make really
any sense or at least nobody can explain
a big thing on on the planes also is and
they're very strict about this in my
experience uh you if you have the your
nose peeking out over the mask that's
inappropriate
that's a
that is not the appropriate way to way
to wear a mask and they'll let you know
i mean why does it matter
nobody can explain that
like at worst if i have my mask on and
my nose is peeking out so i so i can
breathe god forbid
at worst i i have what put myself in
danger
is there much of a risk that through the
air i'm breathing out of my nose i'm
going to infect somebody else
especially if they're wearing their mask
properly
what are the chances of that
statistically
that i could infect somebody else with
just through the the air through my
nostrils
not saying it's impossible what are the
chances
so there's no one can explain that
either
but this is part of the
conditioning can't explain it
doesn't make a lot of sense
but do it anyway and you see this is the
this is not supposed to be the
relationship between a customer and
employee
this is also not supposed to be the
relationship between a citizen and a
government
you know what this is this is the
relationship between a young child and
his parents
that's the relationship
when you've got with very young children
they don't understand anything nothing
makes sense to them you can try to
explain why certain rules are put in
place
but uh their ability to comprehend your
reasons
are
the ability is very limited
so you could say to a two-year-old for
example as we all have said to
two-year-olds
don't run in the street
why well because a car will hit you
why don't i want a car to hit me well
because you could die
what does death mean well two-year-old
doesn't even understand what death is
a two-year-old doesn't know that death
is uh is permanent
they think well do you die and you wake
up tomorrow and everything's fine
so very young children
have to be conditioned in a certain way
to obey rules that they don't understand
and just to obey them
uh based on the trust they have and the
respect they have for their the
authority figures in their lives their
parents
but even even even the the parent-child
relationship even that relationship is
supposed to evolve and mature over time
as the kids grow a little bit older and
they can understand the reasons for
these rules and you start explaining it
to them because it's important that they
know the reasons
so it's not even that that we are being
treated like
children generally it's we're being
treated like toddlers
our relationship now with
the employees on an airplane or the
government is that between is like that
between a parent and like a two-year-old
we're not gonna explain it to you
nobody can explain it but do it anyway
all right now we go to michael mann
who's a climate activist who pretends to
be a scientist and uh who has blocked me
on twitter by the way i just discovered
and very torn up about that he was on tv
explaining why climate denialism is
dangerous and uh must be censored
there's not enough censorship in the
world today and he wants more of it
let's listen
now it's time for you to remove climate
denial videos they pose an even greater
threat to humanity in the long term
explain
yeah that's right i mean climate change
uh you know here we saw nearly 100
people uh die
from these unprecedented tornadoes uh
but if you look at the the total impact
of climate change around the world
wildfires droughts floods heat waves
coastal inundation
climate change is already costing far
more lives than covet 19. it is deadlier
and so the denial of climate change is
deadlier even than the denial of the the
basic science be behind covid19 but
here's the difference
there isn't a huge global
lobby the world's most powerful industry
wealthiest and most powerful industry
the fossil fuel industry that has a
stake in the covet 19 debate
so it's fairly easy for these big tech
companies these social media companies
to stop you know uh showing covet denial
for suppressing covid denial videos and
and posts um there isn't a huge
corporate interest that's going to get
in their way
with climate change it's a whole
different story we are talking about an
effort by the world's largest most
powerful industry the fossil fuel
industry to prevent any meaningful
action on climate and to accomplish that
in part by using social media to promote
denialism and dismissal and here
the social media companies are being
complicit
yeah well climate denialism is uh i
continue to agree that climate denialism
is a
a big problem
if there are people out there who are
denying
climate
denying that the climate exists well
that's
i'm not sure i see the
what sort of greater impact i can have
on society but i think it's hard to
function as a as a as a person in the
world if you deny that the climate
exists
so that's and even climate change denial
i don't agree with that either
if if there's anyone out there denying
that the climate changes
well
that that person i think that person
needs to needs to uh needs to wake up i
agree with that
the problem is i don't think there is
anyone in that category i don't think
anyone denies the climate i don't think
anyone denies that climate changes
i think i think everyone all adults
anyway understand that uh there is a
climate and it changes all the time i
mean the climate is always changing
it changes over the course of a day it
changes
drastically over the course of centuries
and millennia
the question is what is causing that
change
and when we look at the causes
you know to
each individual cause to what degree
can we blame those causes
the question is also whether this is in
fact an apocalyptic scenario and we're
all going to be dead in 10 years or
drowned because the polar ice caps melt
or whatever
so that's the issue
um
he says that this is this is what we're
experiencing now the weather is
unprecedented well we've already talked
about that that's total nonsense
it that that's a claim that you
that we actually know is not true
take the tornado for example
we know that a hundred years ago
because there are records we know that
100 years ago there were there were
worse tornadoes more people dying from
tornadoes
even though again there were fewer
people
the the population was less dense in
more ways than one by the way
and yet more people died
but it's also
to make this kind of statement to call
it unprecedented and he means that he
means in history
there's just no way to support that
we know it's not true because we have on
record worse storms
but even if we didn't have that on
record
the mass the vast majority of of uh
you know of the earth's history
we don't have reliable
records
for individual weather events
as i said a few days ago who
who knows what the tornado situation was
in the continental u.s 500 years ago
there was nobody around to keep records
there were people around but they
weren't keeping records
not that we can rely on anyway
so you can't possibly say that and then
as in
as far as
of course more censorship shutting down
dissent this is not science
and it could be hard to you know that's
something we have to keep in mind it can
be it could be easy to to forget
because we're so used to this now
especially over the last two years
people who pretend to be scientific
authorities
um
treating those who disagree with them as
terrorists
as a danger a threat
but that's how you know someone's not a
real scientist
i don't know anything about this guy but
i feel comfortable putting sarcastic air
quotes around scientists for him
because scientists don't do that
part of the scientific process descent
disagreement
is an essential part of the scientific
process
so anyone who says this is the official
scientific stance on this particular
issue
and you're not allowed to have a
different position
anyone who says that by definition is
not a scientist
all right moving on it may actually come
as a surprise to some people to learn
that members of congress are not banned
from trading stocks while they are in
office
now it seems clear that they should be
given the power that they have over the
economy and over the stock market
to be able to profit in that way just
breeds corruption
but they're not banned is there any good
reason why
members of congress should be allowed to
trade stocks personally individually
while they're in congress well nancy
pelosi was asked about this yesterday
from the only reporter who ever asks uh
real questions and let's find out if
there is a good reason let's let's find
out
madam speaker uh insider just completed
a five-month investigation finding that
49 members of congress and 182 senior
congressional staffers have violated the
stock act um the insider training law
i'm wondering if you have any reaction
to that and secondly should members of
congress and their spouses be banned
from trading individual stocks while
serving the congress no i don't know to
the second one um
any uh we have a responsibility to
report
in the stock
on the stock but i don't i'm not
familiar with that five-month
review but if the people aren't
reporting they should be
because this is a free market in people
where free market economy they should be
able to participate in that
oh
now she cares about the free market
when's the last time you heard nancy
pelosi even say the
the phrase free market
i think it's the first time i've heard
it it sounds odd coming out of her mouth
everything sounds odd coming out of her
mouth
um
but especially that well this is a free
market
people should be free to participate oh
really nancy
interesting that you feel that way now
when it comes to politicians profiting
uh that's when we care about the free
market not for any other reason great
makes a lot of sense okay let's get now
to the comment section
[Music]
if you own a home and have not
refinanced what in the world are you
waiting for mortgage rates are at
historic lows again which means you
could easily drop your rate and monthly
payment
nobody can afford to you know leave
money on the table especially these days
with everything being so expensive save
some money if you can all you've got to
do is call american financing america's
home for home loans take advantage of a
free mortgage review it is completely
free meaning there's no pressure there's
no obligation no upfront fees just a
simple conversation with a salary-based
mortgage consultant somebody who is
going to listen to you and guide you so
you're getting a custom loan that
achieves your goals as well from lower
rates to shorter terms even the ability
to access cash from your equity
they're ready to find you the best deal
possible you could save up to a thousand
dollars a month you may you may even be
able to skip two mortgage payments so
you're there's a lot of upfront savings
there as well and you can pre-qualify
for free by calling
nine forty seven eleven 866-569-4711
eight six six five six nine forty seven
eleven again eight six six five six nine
forty seven eleven uh you wanna do this
now or visit americanfinancing.net
american financing nmls one eight two
three three four nmls consumeraccess.org
ozzie says i love that although matt
hated amazon for taking his book off the
lgbt charts he still defended amazon
against ignorance
yeah
that's not because of any virtue on my
part i just i i hate stupidity even more
than i hate amazon i guess
and so when i hear people saying that uh
amazon
when there was a tornado warning and
funnel clouds have been spotted that
amazon should have sent their employees
out to the parking lot to get in cars
and drive away
um
that's stupidity and i i do hate that
i also hate that i have to
defend amazon so then i hate the
stupidity even more
for what it has forced me to do
trust me says matt walsh's many split
personalities badass ornery person gun
toter cardigan wearing children's book
author aerophobe theocratic fascist
dictator gay straight guy thanksgiving
day fat guy that fat shames other fat
people
badass canceler that decries cancel
culture makeup wearing skinny jean guy
cult leader this dude's all over the
board but the spg just blindly follows
him
i can't i can't disagree with that
assessment either
but that's
part of the cult thing right like we
talked about just following blindly
you don't understand the reason for
anything but you follow
i'm learning you know as an aspiring
cult leader this has been a very
fruitful time the last couple of years
because i can look at other cult leaders
like anthony fauci for example
and i i've i'm taking notes i've picked
up a lot of tips
um
mwdiver says matt the person you heard
clapping for the male swimmer in the
female race
was actually just his flapping against
his leg
we probably can't even hear that
uh but you mean herb sir please be
respectful
todd says hey matt where's the johnny
the walrus merch we need plushies
t-shirts and and official wooden spoons
i love the wooden spoon idea so we do
need to sell some wood spoons but you
can we do have johnny the walrus
merchandise thank you for bringing this
up you can go to dailywire.com
shop
and uh then go to the matt walsh store
there and you'll find all kinds of uh
great merchandise johnny the walrus swag
as well as um
all the other ridiculous memes from the
show
we are we are
greedily profiting from all of it
because we are we can participate in the
free market in that way
um kayla says were the producers messing
with matt with closing the show with
that song or was he in on it his face
was priceless
no i could tell you i was not in on it
i'm pretty sure that was mckenna who did
that
and i've already talked to jeremy about
her and her last day will be tomorrow
sorry you had to find out this way
mckenna
david says is it bad to wish that bad
things happen to an evil person that man
swimming in a women's race is evil
no i actually don't think that it is
i i know for for a lot of christians
they it's it's going to sound scandalous
to them that i said that but
to wish that bad things happen to a bad
person i i don't think that that's that
that is bad
i don't think it's unchristian either
because you know what that is that's a
desire for justice
now if somebody
cuts you off in traffic and now you
are hoping that they get hit by a mack
truck and everybody in the car dies
well that's a problem
because that's not that's not justice
that would be a that would be a
very disproportionate you know
punishment for cutting somebody off in
traffic
but if you are
desiring a proportionate proportional i
should say uh punishment for evil acts
that are done
then then i i think not only is that not
non-christian not only is it not bad but
it's good
i think that if you if you don't wish
for bad things to happen to bad people
in that way for them to suffer
proportional punishments for the wrongs
that they've committed um if you don't
wish that then i think um
that's not charity
that's
indifference
that i think is apathy
and that's another problem that we have
i think in the church is that very often
apathy and indifference are confused
with tolerance and
you know
kindness and charity
so a desire for justice is a very good
thing and if you don't believe me then
go to the bible
always a good source for these things
an even better source than the matt wall
show go to the bible especially the old
testament and especially the psalms
and you're going to find one psalm after
another
dedicated to uh
wishing
that ill befalls evildoers
there are many many beautiful psalms and
then other portions of the bible
dedicated exactly to that so
not only can you wish it but you could
pray for it
you could pray for evil doers to be
punished and you should the daily wire
was first in the nation to sue the byte
administration for their
unconstitutional mandate and we're
getting closer to a million signatures
on our do not comply petition every
single day why well because people are
realizing that if you don't actively
fight back against this and fight for
our freedom the government will take it
we have a goal of reaching one million
signatures which uh would provide a
major boost to our legal challenge we're
almost there we're at over 875 000
signatures right now so go to
dailywire.com do not comply and get your
name on that petition also i'm very
excited to announce a new series
exclusive to daily wire if you've ever
wanted to be a fly on the wall for some
of the ben shapiro
behind the scenes then you're going to
love this in the premiere episode jordan
peterson joins ben for coffee while he's
visiting nashville and they catch up on
their private lives and trade big ideas
great conversation and um and uh the
cameras are rolling the entire time
here's a quick teaser alrighty so i'm
here in nashville with jordan peterson
jordan's spending a lot of time in
nashville in fact i think jordan may
know nashville better than i do last
night you dragged me to robert's western
world and you were like you were like
the the guy of the house like they all
knew you no no luke mccrory was the guy
in the house the guitarist playing
kelly's heroes they're a deadly band
yeah i will say i feel like i was a
little more dressed for it like i was
wearing a t-shirt and a
leather jacket and you were wearing this
yeah
i didn't have my kobe boots i haven't
bought them yet i'll get a cowboy
it was really fun being there with you
oh yeah i know that that was awesome
you're a classically trained violinist i
am yes and you like the music oh yeah i
love that stuff i mean if you're a good
musician you're a
they
good
musician
how to play
sunday special is a lot more formal i
mean i'm coming in with with questions
and it's much less of kind of a
discussion between the two of us and
it's much more of kind of just me
probing and jordan's ideas but this is
much more like how we talk normally i
mean jordan you called me we talked on
the phone like a month ago and this was
basically the same conversation right
this is how we talk about different
topics but yeah different topics but i
mean like this is this is how we talk
when the cameras aren't on us people
really love being in on those
conversations i yeah no i i think that
the fact that people are going to kind
of get the
the
kind of the fly on the wall view of this
kind of conversation is pretty awesome
so you'll be able to see clips of my
conversation with jordan here at the
coffee shop on youtube but if you want
to see the whole conversation which
really is the way you should see it you
need to head on over to dailywire.com or
check us out on the daily wire app
you'll be able to see the whole thing
there and it's it's pretty fantastic
well ben's conversation with jordan
peterson drops tomorrow and will be
available only at dailywire.com so if
you're not a member yet now is the
perfect time to sign up head to
dailywire.com subscribe to sign up today
again that's dailywire.com subscribe to
sign up today so you can watch this show
and many other great pieces of content
as well now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
so today i'm afraid that we must cancel
vice president camille harris for i am
told the third time
i confess that i am reluctant to issue
this cancellation today especially after
jen pasaki just yesterday raised the
issue of greedy meat conglomerates as
she explained big meat is responsible
for much of the inflation that we're
seeing at the grocery store and joe
biden unfortunately has camilla harris
to tackle that problem which is good
because we know that she can handle big
meat but even so despite how useful she
might be i have to cancel her
and i'm canceling her for this speech
which she gave during a holiday
fundraiser for the dnc it's extremely
shocking
objectionable
but take a listen
we must make it clear
democrats stand for workers rights we
stand for women's rights and we believe
that the right of a woman to make a
decision about her own body is
non-negotiable
non-negotiable
[Applause]
democrats stand for voting rights
and we are fighting and we will continue
to fight to pass the freedom to vote act
and the john lewis voting rights
advancement act
[Applause]
we stand for dreamers we stand for farm
workers we stand for our lgbtq plus
brothers and sisters we stand for people
with disabilities we stand for our
children and the planet they will
inherit
now you might listen to that and think
that we accidentally elected a liberal
fortune cookie as vice president indeed
you might say that camilla harris is
speaking in the ancient and sacred
language of the bumper sticker but there
is something far more sinister going on
here i think
first of all let's go through this
quite shockingly
camila harris twice mentions workers she
says we stand for workers
workers rights farm workers rights
this is elitism and classism
as it excludes those americans who do
not work and have never worked and do
not plan on ever working
this is the democrat party's most loyal
and important constituency and kamela
hairs has simply erased them from
existence in this speech
she didn't even bother to mention the
rights of non-workers
she's pretending they don't exist
even though they are the ones who put
the democrats in power to begin with
as if that was not bad enough next the
vice president says that we stand for
women's rights and the rights of women
to make decisions about their own bodies
but obviously what about the millions of
men who become pregnant every year do
they not have rights over their bodies
should we force all of these
distinguished pregnant pregnant
gentlemen in the country to remain
pregnant against their will
apparently a man's uterus is public
property according to the vice president
to make matters worse camilla harris
talks about our lgbtq plus brothers and
sisters
now we're going to try to leave aside
the fact that the full initialism is
lgbtqip2saa
now i know that may sound like the kind
of random assortment of letters and
numbers that you might use as a password
for your gmail account and then
immediately forget the next time you
have to sign in but it's not
that is indeed the full acronym and yet
harris waves away
the qip 2 saa members of the community
and expects them to make do with oh
you're the plus
all of those unique and distinct and
vibrant identities have been reduced to
a mere plus sign by camila harris
the p's pansexuals the two s's two
spirits the aas alcoholics anonymous all
of these marginalized people have been
further marginalized by this exclusion
remember something silence is violence
and if that was not bad enough
she actually has the gall to speak of
lgbtq
brothers and sisters
this kind of gendered language has no
place in a progressive society sure some
members of the community may identify
with the binary concepts of brother and
sister but many exist outside of that
framework entirely
the more gender-neutral and thus
inclusive phrase would have been
lgbtqip2saa
siblings
or even better lgbtqip2saa
individuals of indeterminate gender
gender with whom we share a common
affection traditionally associated with
the sibling relationship
is that so hard to say
well it was a little bit hard to say
actually finally in her most appalling
act of rhetorical brutality she actually
says
she actually says we stand
for people with disabilities
we stand
well there are some members of the
disabled community who cannot stand
in fact we stand as ableist and
exclusionary language we do not all
stand we cannot all stand and there are
those who can who can theoretically
stand and even walk but rarely choose to
like brian stelter for example
all of these people are valid and their
experiences are valid yet camilla harris
deliberately chooses language which
fails to legitimize their lived
experiences
she may have thought she was being
inspiring in her speech but she used
words that were heteronormative ableist
racist sexist transphobic homophobic
elitist classes discriminatory prejudice
bigoted hateful and traumatizing
and i didn't even mention the fact that
the word dreamers was used
uh and has the effect of otherizing
those who identify as insomniacs
literally every phrase she uttered was
problematic it's difficult to describe
the full emotional toll that her words
have taken on the most marginalized and
vulnerable members of our society
i don't know if they'll ever recover
camilla harris should be ashamed
and that is why today she is canceled
for the third time
that'll do it for us today thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pablo vadasky
the show is edited by ali hinkle our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by cherokee heart and our
production coordinator is mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire where we
bring you all the news that you need to
know in 15 minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia hal for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire